[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's kyle trask i think he's the leading
candidate for the heisman feels like
it's his heisman to lose
and it feels like he's an overnight
sensation kyle it took a long time for
you to get to this point
if you were going to sum up your high
school and college career
leading up to this season how would you
do it
um you know i would just say it's been a
crazy journey
it's been just a lot of hard work and
just
persistence and just you know trusting
the process and
at the end of the day you know
i'm glad to be where i am now and i want
to have it any other way
but you were back up in high school did
you start a game in high school
no i never started a game in high school
okay so
how did and then how long did it take
for you started your first game in
florida
uh well i almost got my degree at
florida before i even stepped foot on
the field
so i mean i was going into my uh
i guess i didn't start until my redshirt
junior year that was last year
how do you explain this though that here
you are
you've 31 touchdowns three interceptions
i think you're the leading candidate for
the heisman right now
how do you explain this kyle um
you know i just like i said i just
trusted the process you know
i was back up for i don't know what six
or seven years but
you know in my head i always you know
you know i was going to get that
opportunity
so i kind of just you know grinded it
out and i finally got my shot and i just
tried to make the most of it
what did you learn being a backup
quarterback and and you were a backup
quarterback to
diera king who's a great quarterback at
miami uh
felipe pranks uh was there who i think
is now at arkansas what did you learn
backing these guys up
um and obviously it's very humbling
because you know you're not getting any
attention or anything like that but and
you just kind of have to sit on the
sidelines on game day and you put in
that work all week
but at the same time it taught me a lot
about hard work and you know just
staying consistent in my preparation
because you know you
you're a backup so you're always one
play away from going in the game
and you know if that ever happens you
got to be you know ready to go and just
as prepared as a starter
who was your favorite team growing up
nfl
um you know i grew up in houston so i
was everything houston guys so i was a
huge texans fan growing up
uh did you meet jj watt or deshawn
watson yet
uh no um actually
um i think somebody won like a raffle
to have jj watt come to a pep rally in
high school so
i actually did get the chance to meet jj
white he came to our school at like a
pep rally
i don't know what it was about but he
was just gave us like a 10 minute talk
and left
but it was still pretty cool could be
weird though he could be hitting you
next season in the nfl
one step at a time that would be pretty
cool though
have you ever have you done a heisman
pose with your buddies
no no no no no no no
no i think you just lied to me kyle it's
okay i don't blame you for lying but
i can tell that you probably joked
around a little bit
um i mean probably you know growing up
you know playing in the backyard i would
hit one but you know as of lately
i'm kind of just focused on uh you know
we're really trying to get this uh
national championship that's our team's
main focus
and you know we're just trying to take
it one game at a time right now ah look
at you saying all the right things there
um absolutely uh so this may come down
to you against alabama
got a few games before that but you
expecting to meet alabama for
the chance to play in the final four
um you know obviously we're we're not
blind to that possibility
um you know if that happens you know
they're a great team
it's gonna be a good challenge for us
and you know we'll be ready to go
well congrats so far been uh pretty good
run there but
he's not an overnight sensation took him
a long time to get to this point
good luck against kentucky uh this
weekend kyle we appreciate your time
thank you appreciate it that's kyle
trask the florida quarterback florida's
now
six and one and i think it's his heisman
toulouse